welcome to all of you who have joined us
today my name is kathle Dunn I'm the
coordinator of the National Library of
Medicine associate fellowship program
I'm joined today by current Associates
Ellen theme and Carlette Dennis and by
Alum Associates Louise toe and Amanda
Sawyer
so let's get started
today we're going to talk to you um I'm
going to provide an introduction to the
fellowship and a program overview and
then each of the Alum or current fellows
will give you something about their
experience the projects that they
undertook while at the fellowship and
their steps they've taken after or for
the current Associates what their
current experience is like
um again my name is Castle Dunn and I'm
the National Library of Medicine
associate fellowship program coordinator
um and so let's go move from the agenda
to the fellowship program
the fellowship is a one-year Fellowship
for recent graduates who are interested
in a career in Health Sciences
librarianship
the fellowship will be remote during the
2023-2024 fellowship year
the National Library of Medicine is
currently undertaking a substantial and
substantive renovation that start the
planning for which was started well
before covid and because we were all out
we've decided to keep on staying out to
allow the renovation to come to
completion
so while that's taking place we will
continue to be remote
we will select between four and five
candidates that will form a cohort
during the fellowship year
the year begins July 1st and the first
half of the Year from July through
December is focused on an established
curriculum where you attend one day to
four day sessions so there depends the
days vary where it's where nlm staff
tell you about their work how they
accomplishment accomplish it and the
impact of their work
you learn about Healthcare data and
standards diversity Equity inclusion and
accessibility at nlm and NIH
engagement and Outreach reference and
web services collections both print and
digital cataloging indexing and about
our databases from PubMed the premier
biomedical literature database to
medlineplus an internationally renowned
consumer health resource
the second half of the year is focused
on working on projects proposed by staff
and a week-long visit to hopefully it's
in person sometimes they've been a
hybrid to another Health Sciences
Library in the United States as well as
attendance at the medical Library
Association annual meeting this year
will be in Detroit in May
we will also invest in your professional
development through
um
meetings with nlm leadership
uh your participation and behavioral
assessment workshops resume review
interview assistance negotiation
training and networking each associate
fellow is assigned a mentor based on
their career needs and goals
we use an individual development plan to
guide your specific training needs
so who are we interested in recruiting
well we're interested in recruiting
early career and second career
Librarians who are interested in
advancing Innovation and equity in
biomedical libraries
we are looking for librarians who will
have graduated by June of 2023
or who have graduated no later than June
2018.
if you had an earlier career in any
field and are now moving into libraries
we would welcome your application so
it's early career not early in life so
early career the criteria we use are not
only early in life the criteria we use
to evaluate applications are your work
experience first we look for Library
experience then other relevant
experience then we look at your academic
preparation both in undergraduate and
graduate programs your response to
application questions which are how will
you advance an equitable and Innovative
future for biomedical libraries
and what would make you a great
candidate for the National Library of
Medicine associate fellowship program
then your references we do ask that one
of the references be from a library
School professor and then we make an
overall assessment of we'll be asked for
three references altogether one of which
should be from a library School
professor
then we make an overall assessment of
your entire application
based on what we see as your abilities
and potential since this Fellowship is
for early career Librarians we're
looking less for experience though it
does matter
but more for where you can show your
potential how will you make use of the
fellowship when you're in it
and what will you do with it when you
with what you've learned when you leave
and that can be hard you don't know what
you don't know but we're asking you to
kind of sit and think what do I want to
get how will I participate in this
program and when I leave what do I hope
to be able to accomplish because I've
been in the fellowship
so our alums where are they
um most of our alumni go into Health
Sciences libraries academic libraries or
in some cases a non-traditional
um but health related setting these are
some titles of some of our recent alums
uh one is a clinical librarian at Walter
Reed National military Medical Center if
I were at National Library of Medicine
today instead of in my home I would be
right across the street from Walter Reed
National military Medical Center
someone else one of our alums is the
snomed international
um well for snowmen Internationals she's
the customer relations manager for the
Americas and a collaboration specialist
snomed is an international clinical
terminology
and it's used by a lot of hospitals in
the U.S as well as used internationally
uh and then
um one of our alums is the associate
director for the network of the National
Library of Medicine National Training
office based at the University of Utah
Eccles Health Sciences Library
and does she does training and assists
other trainers who do training across
the United States in health information
I've been coordinating the fellowship
for 15 years and I can say that nearly
all of the fellows have left the program
to take a job or a Next Step that they
wanted to take that that was the thing
that they wanted to do and to a larger
and to a large degree in the location
they wanted to be in sometimes not
always quite the location they wanted to
be in but pretty much all doing the kind
of work that they wanted to do
so if you're interested in applying for
the cohort that will start July 1st 2020
three
the application deadline is January 27th
this this month January 27 2023 at I
believe 11 59 PM eastern time we are
looking for your resume transcripts and
we do look at them we really do
um and at transcripts for undergrad and
graduate and answers to essay questions
or that might be called narrative
statements or application questions
those are the ones I mentioned earlier
and your references once you submit your
application with names and contact
information for your references the
system then prompts the references
they'll send a link to the references to
fill out the reference
you'll be directed from the associate
fellowship program web pages on the
National Library of Medicine website to
a system called zintellect that's where
we'll be capturing your application we
recruit for this program every year so
if this isn't a year that would work for
you consider applying for next year
sorry Louise I'm I'm
pumping right into her into her
statements so my email is listed here on
the slide and I'll put it in chat in a
moment I'm going to turn it over now to
Louise toe who is a recent Alum of the
associate fellowship program she's going
to tell you about her experience but
thank you all for joining us I'm really
so delighted questions in chat or come
off mute and Louise
thanks castles I believe I have control
over his eyes now yes I do okay
um
hey everyone welcome to the webinar
um my name is Louise toe uh and I was an
associate fellow during the cohort year
of 2019 to 2020.
see if it'll move the slides ahead for
me
oh okay there we go
um so I just wanted to briefly talk
about where I'm from
um I grew up and was born on the island
of Oahu specifically in the town of
makiki and that's where I also went to
um undergrad as well as my graduate
programs specifically I went to I
completed a bachelor's degree in ethnic
studies and also a the Dual program of
Library science and education
um see if this slides will
move forward there we go okay
um and in the library program um I was
very interested initially in doing
archives or public librarianship because
um before I went into my graduate
programs I worked at an Arts non-profit
and I did youth programming and I also
managed a photo archive so when I wrote
my essay to enter the program those were
the areas of librarianship that I felt
most interested in
but then during the program
I ended up taking an internship with the
Hawaii Pacific Health hospital system
which consists of four hospitals across
two islands there are kapiolani Pali
Momi Straub and Wilcox and the solo
librarian that managed all the library
for the these four hospitals his name is
Dave Coleman he turned out to be a
really great mentor for me and he taught
me a lot about what it takes to be a
solo librarian for a hospital system so
while working in in the um the library
was called the Arnold Medical Library
but we also just call it the Hawaii
Pacific health library while working
there I did a fulfilled reference
queries and I also developed several
instructional tutorials on accessing the
library's electronic Collections and as
part of the work we relied really
heavily on one of the products that was
is offered by the National Library of
Medicine and that that is
the dockline product
there we go so
um dockline is an interlibrary loan
system that hospital libraries heavily
rely on because due to the limited
budgets they use dockline to give their
patrons access to Publications that they
wouldn't otherwise be able to access and
so being able to utilize that product
and then become familiar with the
network of the National Library of
Medicine which is nlm's largest outreach
program that kind of gave me an
introduction to what nlm does for for
all of the nation
um and so because I liked the internship
so much and I liked being in the
hospital setting that's where I became
interested in Health Sciences
librarianship and then that eventually
led to my learning about
um nlm's associate fellowship program
so projects
um
kathle mentioned that in the fellowship
you're going to be working on several
projects throughout the year and I'm I
think they're they're broken up between
the fall projects which are slightly
smaller and then there's also spring
projects which are bigger for the fall I
picked a project that intimidated me
um I think I saw the fall as an
opportunity to learn something new and
to also develop more technical knowledge
um uh in areas related to health science
Health Sciences librarianship this
project was led by a staff scientist and
it investigated the valuability of
wikidata which is a structured editable
computable database as a means to make
Wikipedia and info button resource in
electronic personal health records
now if all that sounds very confusing
and you don't know what that means
that's okay I didn't know what it meant
either when I was reading the
description for the project
um but that's what sort of attracted me
to pick up the project
um I really was trying to focus on the
fact that I wanted to learn about the
mechanics behind consumer health
um so This research project produced a
report that Illustrated current ways
patients access their health records and
the technology of Wiki data as well as
info buttons and also standard
biomedical terminologies
um after the project I felt like my mind
was like more primed to understand how
health information technology Works in
and also the project really helped me
gain an appreciation for
um you know standards and their role in
enabling interoperability
all right so for the spring I chose a
project that largely utilized projects
or skills that I had already in my felt
that I already had in my wheelhouse and
that was like project coordination and
Outreach um skills that I'd gained from
previous work experiences at nonprofits
um and also through the internship it
was really just the subject matter
expert uh subject matter that really uh
attracted me to these projects one of
the projects involved serving in a an
executive secretary capacity for a newly
formed policy working group that was
charged with drafting a privacy
principles document that addresses
privacy with respect to emerging
Technologies such as artificial
intelligence and machine learning this
project really interested me because I
felt like privacy is a topic that is
only going to increase in scrutiny and
knowing a thing or two about privacy I
think is is beneficial in the long run
so the work involved organ organizing
meetings creating briefing docs
recording minutes and synthesizing a lot
of opinions into one report
and the next project
let's see
the other project that I chose was
supporting the environmental health
information partnership which is an nlm
training and Outreach collaboration with
hbcus tribal colleges and universities
as well as other minority serving
institutions
I did my undergrad in ethnic studies as
I mentioned so I wanted to learn about
programs that promote Health Equity and
the project initially focused on
strategic transformation of nhip but
based on some comments that we received
from the executive committee the project
then pivoted to an oral history but then
we were interrupted by the pandemic so
we weren't able to complete those
activities
um but all in all I would say that the
methodology that I went with picking
projects I aim to initially challenge
myself with something that I was really
uncomfortable with and then I sent spent
the second half of the year on projects
that aligned with my values and I would
say being flexible is also key because
with projects uh the status and I guess
goals can change so I would say it's
helpful to have your own definition of
what success means for each of your
projects
all right moving forward
there we go
um so as far as benefits I felt that
participating in the fellowship
um really helped me learn a lot about
large Federal libraries
um such as like how decision making
plays out in a really tall hierarchical
structure and also about Federal funding
um and Congressional Appropriations as
well as Contracting
um and so I felt like you know the
policy team helped with that but as also
being in the environment as in the role
of a contractor kind of gives you a feel
for the way Dynamics work in the federal
Workforce
um I was also fortunate to be at nlm
really at the same time that they were
looking to hire
um a large group of early career
professionals uh through the pathways
program for recent graduates
um having a step in the door through the
fellowship definitely helped me get
hired I would say
um
all right so now in my current role with
the office of Engagement and training I
started out by managing a variety of
Community Partnerships including leading
a large virtual NIH event for high
school students and also working with
the children's in at NIH and for those
of you who may not be familiar the
children's in it's kind of like a
residential place like home for families
with children's children and teens and
young adults who are participating in
clinical trials at NIH
um since then my role has changed
um I'm now managing my now my main role
is now managing
um a digital Communications tool which
is called the nlm technical bulletin it
provides updates about nlm's products
and services
um so in addition to the maintenance of
operations I also lead planning around
modernization to improve the user
interface and also back-end management
in addition to that I also serve on the
training team oops
sorry about that
I also serve on the training team where
I produce instructional webinars on
nlm's products uh like for example a
couple days ago I presented on an annual
um for an annual webinar on the updates
of medical subject headings which are
controlled vocabulary for indexing
articles in PubMed
oh I guess it's jumped forward a little
bit
um and then PubMed I think Castle
briefly mentioned what PubMed is but
it's a free database for biomedical
literature citations really every
physician and health researcher knows
about PubMed
um and so on this slide is my email
address
um I'd be happy to answer any questions
that you might have
um for me about the associate Fellowship
um and I'm going to transition now to
Amanda who cool definitely provide more
information about PubMed
all right let me see if I have control
of the slides here
there we go okay hello everyone my name
is Amanda Sawyer and I was a member of
the 2020 2021 associate fellow cohort we
were the first year to be fully virtual
obviously things in 2020 looked very
different than they had the years before
that
um so our year was I think a bit of a
learning process as far as virtual years
go but it was a great experience for me
and then like Louise said I currently
work at ncbi I'm a contractor
um for mcbi as a part of of nlm and I'm
a Contractor on the team that manages
PubMed that database of biomedical
literature
so a little bit about my background
um I actually did not have a Health
Sciences background prior to joining the
fellowship other than I did work a a
brief contract job at a pharmaceutical
company and I'm going to
apologize in advance I have a dog and
she frequently makes appearances and
webinars and I can see her getting
worked out
um okay so I I worked briefly for a
pharmaceutical company and Records
management but my background before the
fellowship was actually in museums I
have a ba and an M.A from Baylor
University
um my research interests originally in
my career were focused on collections
management for digital collections as
well as accessibility of digital
Collections and I had worked for a few
years in both museums as well as
academic libraries before I decided to
go back to school
um I'd been working in an academic
library and I needed the mlis degree in
order to advance in my career so I went
to the University of Pittsburgh that's
where I lived at the time University of
Pittsburgh has kind of a unique program
where full-time students finish in just
one year or three semesters so I started
in August I finished in August of the
next year and I started the fellowship
almost immediately after I graduated
uh the University of Pittsburgh had
redesigned their Library science
curriculum at the time that I started
and they were focusing more on data
management and data science in addition
to your more traditional archives and
other Library science curriculum and so
I got a lot of training in that and
those were things that I also was doing
in my academic role I worked in
scholarly Communications and I was using
python to help them do some collections
analysis and understand their collection
a bit better so when I saw the
fellowship advertised that was the part
that really drew me in is the data
science nlm has a pretty strong focus on
data science for Health Sciences
I apologize
yay
okay so again it was the focus on data
science that really drew me into nlm at
first and then also the opportunity to
do something in my career where I felt
like I was really making a difference
and having an impact on people's lives
my my brief start working for a
pharmaceutical company convinced me I
was not content to just work anywhere I
wanted to work somewhere with a mission
and values that aligned with
um with my own and nlm kind of gave me
that opportunity
um and so when I was interviewing
because I didn't have that Health
Sciences background that some people
come into the program with I was pretty
nervous about that but I decided to
focus my application materials on my
existing data science skills and then my
desire to grow more in that area and why
I hope Sciences made sense like why I
wanted to continue my career in Health
Sciences and I think that ultimately
that's what made me a good fit for the
programs and also the program a good fit
for me as well ultimately
um I mean this is just a screenshot of
PubMed this is the database that I work
on now
so I'll talk a bit about my projects as
well I saw there was a question in the
chat about the freedom to choose what
you want to do it's yes you get to
choose your projects they are based off
of what nlm staff put into we call it
the job jar
um so uh staff members propose projects
based off of needs that the library
currently has and then you as a fellow
get to go through there and apply and
talk with staff and choose what you want
to do so I did a total of five projects
five individual projects during my time
in the fellowship I think being virtual
allowed me to take on a few more than
maybe I would have done otherwise
um
but I'm a person who really needs to
learn things in like a practical real
life situation I love reading I love
learning things in theory but until I
really get my hands into it I don't feel
like I understand it so that was a huge
draw for me for the fellowship as well
and so my first
um
my first project that I did I actually
worked with another associate fellow on
this mesh is the medical subject
headings controlled vocabulary and it's
used to index citations in PubMed and so
the process for proposing new mesh terms
each year you as a person who maybe uses
mesh you can write into our help desk
and propose new terms that you think
should be included and once a year staff
have to go through and evaluate those
and see if they meet certain criteria
that we have
um and in the past that was always done
manually and when there's you know maybe
100 200 proposed new terms that's a very
time consuming process so a colleague
and I wrote a script in Python to do
some of that process automatically some
of the PubMed searching we used the
e-utilities API and wrote a script for
that to be done automatically not all of
it can be done you still need a human to
review and look at things but cutting
out that first step of kind of like
repeat searching things sped things up
quite a bit
another project I did I wanted to get
some more experience in qualitative
analysis in addition to quantitative
analysis so I was a part of a team that
evaluated responses that came in on a
request for information you know when
the government sends out
uh it's making changes or sends out
wants more information on something
they'll put out a request for
information
um and this particular one was about
common data elements so the survey went
out there was a time period where the
responses came in and then we did a
qualitative analysis and wrote a paper
and a report on that to be given to nlm
leadership and NIH leadership
and then the third project that I will
highlight here for you
um was about real world data or
observational data
um this turned into a year-long project
and it for me it was the most
challenging project that I tackled while
I was in the fellowship I worked with a
staff scientist at Listerhill that's
another division of nlm
and our goal was to look at real world
data or observational data which is
um this is these are ways that
researchers can get information about
health and get
um
basically there's clinical trial data
where you get like that highest level of
evidence and then real world data is
something that's secondary so an example
is like Medicare data there's a lot of
data that is collected about patients
and about drugs and conditions that they
have and we can learn a lot about the
impact of those medications by looking
at that data but it's not the same thing
as a clinical trial so there are these
databases that exist that hold these
types of data and the staff scientists I
worked with wanted to get a better
picture of what does the literature
landscape look like and then where are
their gaps in the literature so we took
the mesh vocabulary that I mentioned
earlier and did an analysis of that and
identified some of the gaps in the
literature and then it turned into a
spring project where we looked at that
same type of data and how it was being
reported in PubMed and analyzing our
Publishers supplying the information
that they're supposed to be supplying to
PubMed because the Publishers all
ultimately responsible for reporting
that
so that was a really cool project we we
did a lot of work on that and it
actually turned into a conference paper
for me as well as MLA presentations
several of my projects did and then
finally I'll close out on my experience
by talking about the group project that
my cohort did this was another really
challenging project for me
um in 2020 the NIH launched a pre-print
pilot where they made some pre-prints
that were written by NIH researchers
available in PubMed
um so our group took a look at those
pre-prints and looked at them on
platforms where comments were left on
them and the goal was to see
um does making scientific literature
available earlier invite more uh or
provide more opportunities for
commentary for
um more rigorous research for kind of
democratizing the peer review process
and getting more voices involved and
then also is it resulting in
um
better research on the end once it's
published in its final version in a
journal so we looked at those are really
big high lofty questions we looked at
kind of a small subset of that this was
again a project that really challenged
me it my data science skills grew quite
a bit I was just like self-taught when I
came into the program and then I grew
quite a bit through this project as well
as the real world data one that I
mentioned and then I was able to take
those skills and the things that I
learned and take those into job
interviews and like Louise said I I
definitely benefited from the
connections that I made during the
program I'm like I said I'm a Hands-On
learner I really needed these projects
in order to feel like I was gaining that
experience but it was also the
connections and the networking that I
was able to do throughout the program
that I think were some of the biggest
benefits for me coming out of it so I
um in the spring of my fellowship here I
learned about the position that I
currently hold and applied for it and I
learned about it through the connections
that I had made in the library and
ultimately it definitely helped getting
my foot in the door for That interview
process and I'm I'm very happy to be
working at PubMed and on the team that
manages it
um so I will wrap up my part of the
presentation here
um again I'm Amanda you are welcome to
contact me a few questions about my
experience about the fellowship about
PubMed you can write to me about Putnam
but I definitely recommend contacting
our help desk first they will help you
more but
I would love to talk to you more about
my experience please feel free to reach
out and now I'm going to turn the
presentation over to Carlin
hi everyone my name is Carla Dennis and
I'm a current nlm associate fellow for
the
2022-2023 cohort
um can you go to the next slide please
thank you
um so just a brief history about myself
I'm currently in New Orleans Louisiana
since the fellowship is 100 remote I
graduated from Dillard University which
is an HBCU in this area
um with my BA in accounting and then
um somehow some way I ended up working
in public libraries for about 10 years
um during that time of being a page to
an associate I was heavily encouraged by
those around me my supervisors to
actually go to library school so about
year five I decided to apply to
Louisiana State University where I
received my
mlis
and also a certificate in records and
information management
um I continued working at the library
during that time so I was full-time in
school and full-time at work
I also intern with the Louisiana Supreme
courts in the law library and I also
worked with the Archdiocese of New
Orleans in their records and archives
Department
um it was during that time after covid
happened when it first originally
happened that I found myself answering a
lot of questions about public health
people wanting to know more information
so I found myself on nih's website a lot
um and that was when I
sort of kind of remembered that while I
was in school I had actually applied for
this fellowship before um it was like at
the beginning of my second year at LSU I
did not get it which was fine but when
um it came the thought came around again
I said well let me apply again you never
know what's happened and magically I'm
now here at the fellowship
um so that was an amazing opportunity it
just showed me that even when you don't
get selected in the beginning you can
still try again and you never know what
could happen
um right now the fellowship is really
amazing I really really enjoy it I enjoy
being around my cohort we talk to each
other all the time so even though it's
remote we still are going to interact
with the people that are going through
this process with you as well we just
finished up our fall project I'm going
to talk a little bit about the two that
I selected
um one's out with updating the deia
collection the print and Digital
Collection for NIH
and the other was about Outreach and
engagement with the Health Services
Research Community I really enjoyed
working with all four of my sponsors
they were really just helpful and really
encouraging when I had questions when I
was a little confused about certain
things we would have meetings and we
would just talk everything out just to
try to make sure we all were on the same
page and it was just very very
comforting
um one of the reasons why I decided to
go into the fellowship was because I
really wanted more experience and to
learn more about the Health Sciences and
so I kind of feel like the projects have
really helped me to
develop an understanding about all the
things that are affecting everyone
around us
um I think that my time in public
libraries really helped to push that
narrative for me and that's one of the
things that I really appreciate about
the fellowship
um some of the things that I'm actually
looking forward to in the spring in
addition to right now we are actually
taking our spring project so we have a
lot to choose from and so it's been a
little interesting about how that works
and trying to make sure that I'm getting
everything that I want to get from this
Fellowship another thing is the spring
practicum
um
basically how that works is that you're
going to be looking at different Health
Science libraries or different Health
Science organizations
um contacting them to see if you can
Shadow them for up to seven days
um in any state
and so right now we're working on that
as well so I'm really excited about that
and also just interacting more with
different individuals who currently work
in Health Sciences we have had a lot of
opportunity to speak to a lot of
different people from the president of
of MLA
um
all the way up to the director of the
NIH
um well in LM
um so it has been really really amazing
uh next slide
if y'all have any questions for me you
can always contact me my email is right
here and I will be more than happy to
answer any questions that you have thank
you
hello uh hi my name is Ellen theme I am
also a current associate fellow
um and um you can go ahead to the next
one uh I am so excited to be speaking
with you today sorry my dog just decided
that he also needs attention um and he's
very large so his face might show up
um so
um next slide please uh as I said my
name is Ellen I
um graduated from the University of
Missouri high school in May of 2022 with
my mlis
um
I
didn't really expect to go to school uh
and so uh to undergrad I mean to and so
uh getting through that program and
making my way here has been
just really phenomenal experience
um I as I mentioned I'm from Missouri I
now live in Arkansas which is great
being able to do the fellowship remotely
um and so the way that I learned about
the fellowship was that I had current
associate fellows speak
um to me in one of my library School
classes and then since I didn't really
have an academic background I was really
interested and I sort of shaped my
library School experience around coming
to the fellowship
um and so I took classes I participated
and got my chis certification with MLA
um and I tried to make my way here so um
I uh also during that time pursued
um a fellowship through the uh Institute
of Museum and Library services imls and
received that so that I could pursue
um
Medical Health Sciences education
outside of the library school as a
special Grant and so
um that I think was really instrumental
in helping me understand sort of the the
landscape that I was going to be going
into if I pursued medical librarianship
so
um mostly for my portion I just wanted
to
say that um
I'm really excited for everybody to be
applying and I'd love for you to talk to
me if you have any questions about uh
joining the program I think it's really
important to me that
everybody that wants to try uh to be
part of the fellowship does and so
please let me know if I can help with
anything
um and I'm just so excited to be here
and to see you all here so I want to
make sure we have time for the interview
uh tips portions so if we can skip to
the next slide please
um
we just have some application tips here
um the one that's bolded was mentioned
by a couple of folks um and so I will
open it up now for other uh presenters
or folks to provide their own tips or if
anybody wants to ask questions I think I
just really want to make sure that
everybody gets to ask all the things
that uh you may not know because I
certainly didn't going in
um so uh Amanda Carlette Louise Castle
Ellen thanks so much and I see Carlette
has her hand up
um so I just wanted to say as it relates
to the bolded one
um me and Ellen had a conversation about
this when we were getting ready for this
presentation
um so when I applied for the fellowship
and I had my first interview
uh I was really really really nervous
and so I had a feeling that I didn't
answer like a particular question
correct
and so one of the things that I do like
people tend to do is to send thank you
emails and I went and applied the fact
that I knew I answered this question not
to the best of my ability and I answered
it within the email
um after getting in the fellowship
Castle told me that that was one of the
reasons that led to me getting to the
next step was the fact that in my thank
you email from the first interview I
actually addressed that question
um so you never know what a thank you
email can actually lead to so I would
say make sure that you always try to
even when you think for a second that
maybe this was wrong maybe this was
right to just try to be open to putting
yourself out there
thanks Carlette um a good comment and it
was exactly right
um I think the committee didn't think
that some of your one part of your
interview was interview was strong but
everyone when we met to discuss who we
wanted to invite to join the cohort
um said well she turned it around and
she made it work and it wasn't just that
it was a thank you it was a follow-up
and it was uh um like a turnaround thing
and it's kind of a our director will
tell you it's the Director of National
Library of Medicine we'll say it's not
the mistake you make it's what you do
next so you really showed us sort of
what you did next
um and that was that was quite true I
mean you had to do a good enough
interview it wasn't the only thing but
uh just it was um it is possible for you
all to
um you know influence your your future
and and to
um to mitigate something that you might
think was a mistake I saw Louise you had
your hand up momentarily I don't know if
you've rethought it or I did I mean it's
sort of related but I I was thinking
maybe we should um open it up for any
questions that folks might have before
we go on and if no one has questions
then then I will go okay but yeah does
anyone want to come off mute if you have
any questions I see some people are
putting them into chat
um earlier people uh Julie I think have
asked about interviews in both Carlette
and I think Ellen mentioned uh answered
the question but I didn't want you to
think I well okay I didn't see it so I
didn't see it so I would like to answer
it now which is
um once we get to Applications I have
there's a screening committee that will
evaluate your entire application package
and then make a decision about inviting
about 20 people for a screening
interview and uh it'll be about half an
hour we we will send you the questions
in advance nothing trick about any of it
we usually ask the current Associates if
they'll be buddy up so we'll you would
get a buddy
um so very open very transparent and
then the screening committee meets and
discusses the 20 people that we screen
interviewed and from there we invite 10
usually people to do a second round of
interviews with a different group of
people and at that point and I do very
much mean this I would take any of the
10 that we make those offers to but we
will make an offer to about four to five
I don't know how many for next year
um so that is our process the second
round of interviews I we have to find
out if we should you can tell us in the
chat you think we should get you the
questions in advance we could we did we
didn't last time but we did for the
first round
uh so um
yes I sent you the names of the
interviewers in advance the first round
is very very open and clear the second
round we still sent you the names of the
people I don't think we sent the
interview questions the different people
answer differently
references yeah they're gonna get so
when you enter everything into the
system into zintellect
um I haven't done it so I'm theorizing
this is what happens then and I have had
it confirmed for me when you submit the
application the system then sends a
Lincoln up to a form for your uh
um references to fill in
um so Julie
um yes I was wondering would this
program be a good fit for somebody very
interested working like in a biomedical
Library specifically with
um health and management and biology
biomedical professionals basically
um more like one-on-one or would you say
that this is a better program a program
better suited towards people wanting to
work for like medical librarian
organizations
it is a good program if you want to go
on and work with researchers I will say
that's not the immediate experience that
you would get at nlm but you're going to
get the experience of working and
learning from people who make products
like PubMed PubMed Central the pre-print
archive Gene databases medlineplus
consumer database you'll get to know a
lot about their our products which
people use and that it lets you work
with researchers better
there is another library on campus
they're also somewhat remote called the
NIH library that actually does work with
the NIH researchers so
um I always tell that people they're
kind of like the real library on campus
because they look and act a lot more
like a library than National Library of
Medicine does we have a much I would say
broader scope in what we do
um so anyway I I think it is valuable
and we have had people who have done
that but if you come thinking I'm going
to get to work for with research right
away that's not the case we could
probably make connections maybe but the
focus is on the National Library of
Medicine
and Louise will probably do a better
answer than me Amanda oh I just wanted
to follow up on that but you have a
reasonable amount of unstructured time
in the fellowship to pursue professional
development opportunities and to get
trainings and one way that I used that
time is that I reached out to Librarians
that I saw doing work that I was curious
about and said will you meet with me I
want to learn more about your job and
how you got here so I got a lot of that
experience that doesn't necessarily come
directly through the fellowship
Curriculum by seeking people out on my
own introducing myself and I think
you'll find that people are most people
are pretty willing to have those
conversations and I identified people by
going to webinars and trainings and
saying like oh that looks really
interesting and then I just follow up
after that as well as like keppel said
the NIH Library I met with people from
there quite a bit and took some like
one-on-one lessons from people there so
there's a certain amount of the
fellowship at least in my experience
that can be customized to fit what you
want to do within health science
librarianship
thank you perfectly said Amanda thank
you and thank you for referring to it as
unstructured time and not free time that
is good good language use so please
yeah it's related to this um you know
based on whatever projects are proposed
you do have the opportunity
um if if it does come up in the projects
to work one-on-one with certain
researchers and staff scientists like
Amanda and I know we we got to have
one-on-one
um projects with
um people from Lister Hill and so they
do a lot of like biomedical
Communications research
um so I'm not sure if that's the area
that you're particularly interested in
or if you were like specifically
librarianship topics
um that that I think are broader and I
speaks more to what capital was saying
about products for libraries
um that that may be more the area that
um we the fellowship would
be involved in as opposed to specific
research
yes thanks Louise for that clarification
so nlm does have researchers there's an
intramural research program
but primarily their research is
um computer-based computational biology
or semantic
um they've done stuff with semantic
Medline natural language processing uh I
used to be able to say nlm does not have
any wet Labs but that's not that's not
completely true now we have a researcher
who's recruited to nlm in the last
couple years who has a lab at the
national heart lung Blood Institute and
at nlm so she's in both institutes and
she does have a wet lab which is uh not
computer-based
um so that there so our research is
basically the computers with computers
uh
yes
thank you you're welcome any other
questions trying to think I did as the
one about applications
um
I I will say I
sometimes I follow up and ask people who
started the application but didn't
finish it if I get an opportunity I do
email them
um and
um more often than I would like to I
hear people say oh I didn't think I was
qualified so I didn't continue the
application
um and I look at what their
qualifications are and I I don't tell
them because nobody here needs to hear
it after the fact but a lot of times
they would have been very qualified so
they were qualified to apply
and in some cases I can tell just by
looking that they would have made
probably our first cut and been in the
screening interview round so
um it's a lot to gather I do understand
that it's a it's not just applying with
a resume and a cover letter it's a
resume answers to specific questions
transcripts and naming references so I
do understand that it is quite a bit to
to put in
um but uh
uh you know I would just encourage you
not to cut to count yourself out
um it may not be the right thing for you
but uh if that's the case then don't
apply uh but if you think I really would
like it but I don't know you know think
about applying um because uh don't don't
be the one who counts yourself out
um count yourself in and then and then
talk to us and we can make it work and
the other part of that too is we do ask
for official transcripts uh but I know
sometimes universities it can be hard if
we get your unofficial transcript that's
fine then we can follow up and get the
official one
um I I know if people have applied for
federal jobs with USA jobs it's a little
bit unforgiving we're not quite as
unforgiving we're a different system and
so if you got in touch with me and say
I'm having trouble with this or that we
can usually help get you over the Finish
Line I'd rather be able to talk to you
than not so Maria Elena
hi can you hear me yes
okay
um I know that um the um the time period
for graduation uh from a program it goes
back to 2018.
yes I I'm I'm just wondering I'm not uh
really thinking about this year's round
of applications but perhaps in the
future does degree have to have to be in
library science or could it be uh
related a related field
um because I have a more recent
graduation date but it's a different
program not Library science per se
we are looking for recent graduates in
library or information science for to be
within that five-year time period
um so that is our that is our
sort of Zone
um and I am seeing a page you would ask
if you don't graduate until fall of 2023
yeah we're looking for graduates to have
graduated by June
um and I don't have to make the painful
decisions to say
make exceptions or not which I I would
not want to have to do I'm Bound by our
system and the system will not let you
apply so just so you know that it well
it's restricted
okay because there's there is a program
that most of the courses are Lis courses
um but again the degree I mean I already
have the the mlis degree
um but this was an extension extension
and it was primary uh Library Lis
courses so that's why I'm wondering if
it's close enough to be able to so when
I'm sorry because I asked when was the
mlis degree
uh that I graduated in um in December
2018.
um but the other degree
um is strategic intelligence USF
um 2000 the last last fall last 2021.
yeah and we're looking for the one that
you got 2018 and it would need to be by
June okay
thank you
are there other questions we just have a
few minutes and we did leave a decent I
think amount of time for questions and I
appreciate the ones that have come in
the chat I think Carlette was asking uh
references did people so Christy it was
your question answered
about
yes I hope I did I said do our
references don't need to write anything
until they receive communication not
specifically from nlm but from the
zintellect system
so that's the one that will send out the
email and we we do have staff who will
follow up so between the 27th when it
closes and that following week uh staff
are following up to see you know can we
get the reference in they're contacting
your references to make sure that
they're coming in
um and we will review an application
with fewer than the three references
you're just scored down slightly because
of that because we because we don't have
the full full packet
um this is Wendy
yes hi if I may ask a question yeah
absolutely I think Kathleen had asked if
if we're to include the Bachelor and
master's degrees transcripts I'm not
sure if that question was answered oh
I'm sorry because I apologize yeah we do
ask for your undergraduate and graduate
you don't need to include the associate
degree
just undergraduate and graduate thank
you yes
and we do we do look at them
thank you for that
I don't know if there are any final
questions this has just been very
unexpectedly fun for me on a kind of
gray day in the DC area so thank you all
for that
um
I I'm happy to take questions afterwards
email me this is my job and I love
talking to people and love answering
questions and I know each of the
associate fellows uh both current and
Alum are sincere in offering their email
and uh and uh
willingness to answer questions and
we're getting around to thank you so I
do know uh this is yeah it is a paid
position oh good yes money's important
uh we're at the we offer a stipend at
the level of a gs9 step one for DC pay
locality so we Peg it to the federal
um stipend amount it was 61
247 you guys could correct me for
but it'll go up because the federal
employees got a raise so we'll make it
up to whatever the gs9 step one is
um so it it is that amount and then we
provide an additional amount towards
your health insurance
so Wendy
thanks again
um
does the undergraduate does it have to
be can it be from any University
anywhere in the world
yeah yeah okay thank you
all right so thank you so much I'm gonna
stop
sharing my screen wave to you all in the
boxes uh thank you for coming and I'm
gonna uh and the and the session in a
moment Wendy your hand still up is there
anything else or I know sometimes I
leave my hand up too I'm sorry that's
okay all right all right well thank you
all very much it is really our great
pleasure and uh thank you Michael and
Lisa um thank you for the support
bye